Japan is aging too much and
a lot of unbelievable things have happened recently
Japan is aging too much and recently
Godzilla has stopped emitting rays I
wonder if the half-life has come Japan is aging  The population has progressed too much, and
the other day the
Great Buddha of Kamakura descended from whom and lay down.The
aging has progressed too much, and recently an anime featuring Boruto's son as the main character has been announced.  I was
diagnosed with that, so now it seems that I am
called a regular man.The aging of the population is progressing too much, and
recently Hikaru Utada
released the song Last Love.
So, some
politicians are saying why not?
Most of the people who call it seem to have never seen it in real life,
so they don't know what color it is.  The
population is aging too much and it's
already 5 years of Reiwa, so it's not
scary.  There are
no Pokemon to announce The aging is too advanced, and the
janitor of a nursing home
lives in a nursing home. Summer is too hot in Japan.
3 The aging population is too advanced and the
most popular laptops still
have CD drives The
point is that the joke is not true or false The
aging is too advanced and the most popular
cosmetics  It's a hairpiece I want it The
aging is progressing too much and
almost every week the
funeral home in town
sends me a flyer asking if it's about time to start preparing.
But Doraemon
uses the door everywhere Japan is aging too fast and
recently
Son Goku's hair has turned gray hot Japan is
aging so fast that the
moment you drive a new car it becomes a used car
What do you mean by saying that's normal?